salut comme le mois dernier je vous fais
un blog un seul coup c'est tout ce qui
s'est passé au mois devrait enfin
quasiment tous parce que parfois j'ai
pas la vidéo avec moi il ya tout ce qui
se passe en tournée est rarement ce qui
se passait à paris pourtant il s'est
passé quelques trucs cool par exemple je
suis allé chez karine hersant et victor
barros vous savez ceux qui ont fait la
faq avec moi tant des musiciens même moi
je me suis essayée à chanter avec eux
mon attention à lester b
[Musique]
les ménages
c'est parti pour le lot 2 février
[Musique]
saluons né le 3 février c'est reparti
pour le blog mensuelles il ya quelques
jours j'ai mis le vlog du mois de
janvier c'est plutôt bien accueilli je
suis content par contre y en a
quelques-uns d'entre vous qu'on trouvait
que c'était un petit peu trop long 20
minutes je sais pas combien celui là il
fera puisque c'est tout le mois après on
voit mais si vous trouvez ça trop long
ce que je peux comprendre regardez les
ans plusieurs fois c'est aussi bête que
ça
alors j'en mets qu'un et puis vous
pouvez le faire en plusieurs fois on est
à toulon ou rom city il fait noir avec
gary there il est aux gars isr est ce
qu'ils s'accouplent comme le diable aux
orres cf la vidéo du mois dernier on ne
sait pas alors qu'est ce qui se passe ce
mois ci monsieur vous dire ce qui se
passe il se passe que évidemment je suis
repassé sur le livre là je vais
travailler à fond sur le premier jet que
j'ai sorti le mois dernier en un mois on
ne bat que pas son travail qu'est ce que
c'est joli toutes ces lumières le flash
des projecteurs du zénith de toulon
dureau room city de toulon ça mais ça
marche aussi
nous sommes le 15 janvier la
représentation d'hier s'est très bien
passé merci d'être venu à tout pour se
vider la jour d'hui joue deux fois avec
peu d'écart entre les deux
représentations du coup je sais pas
comment on va s'organiser pour se voir
là je suis logé dans un petit et mon
pote
il ya une inondation donc j'ai prévenu
le propriétaire invités à qui il se
passait une inondation mais qu'il
fallait peut-être la gérer ce à quoi m a
répondu il va falloir mettre du destop
c'est parce que tu dois avoir trop de
cheveux trop de cheveux trop de cheveux
alors je veux bien avoir les cheveux
épais mais déjà ils sont pas très long
on est quand même assez content car
depuis ma plus tendre enfance mon front
n'est pas trop garnis en termes de
cheveux dont on est plutôt cool ce
bassiste foot hand algues loupé dans le
port de toulon
durand et pas de café on veut du café
gary le stade rochelais
la rochelle a gagné au rugby et du coup
on essaie d'être un petit parce qu'on a
gagné face à toulon tu vois il fallut
proche de nous rejoindre
si vous me suivez sur instagram vous
avez vu que je monte une deuxième
technique pour devenir riche toujours
sur gary je crois que pour en trouver
une troisième fois que je me lève de
bonne heure commence à se méfier les
proches il vient de nous rejoindre et il
a laissé un peu de matos sur la table
du coup on est soit en lui faisant un
chèque comme ça en nous et entre nous
deux et là ça commence à devenir des
fous alors je
je file me sens un numéro de carte bleue
et c'est plus pour les abonnés non on va
prendre un choix parce que vous vous
allez abusé on le sait vous avez abusé
non bah on va plutôt lui prendre un
chèque on est combien gaiser le 5
février en même temps là je pense qu'il
fallait le faire pour avoir un doute sur
le moi je peux te dire qu'il fait un
petit temps des familles voilà le dessus
de ta beauté du sud
on nous avait dit venez dans le sud il
ya 150 % de beau temps par an 150 % de
jours de beau temps
je pense qu'on s'est appauvrie daniel
pour tous ceux qui croient que les
artistes dorment de luxueux hôtels
voici la réalité un seul lit hagard isr
1 fabien heures cherche patator
découvrons les activités dominicales
d'un gars resort il m'a dit je travaille
en carrière je travaille pour ma
carrière c'est bien ça allez on se
prépare on arrange les affaires et c'est
parti pour la quatrième ronde cited
tullow on est dans les loger car isaure
juste avant de faire la dernière
représentation du rock city et alors on
s'est tapé intrigue qui auront quatre
joueurs aguerris
c'est par rapport à tous les systèmes
qui existaient pour gagner de l'argent
d'ailleurs il ya une phrase pour çà et
là une phrase pour savoir quand est-ce
que tu vas te faire a relégué ses sites
mon ami tu veux gagner de l'argent ça ça
c'est une bonne phrase darna quito on a
décrété que c'était les armes à quito du
coup on a monté trois système de chat
promod comment gagner de l'argent joue
mais les vidéos jeux des amis sur
instagram facebook twitter si vous me
suivez pas vous pouvez y aller lien
description je voulais mais peut-être y
en aura plus d'ici là je vous lui
mettrais mes lacets les trois qu'on a
fait on n'est pas peu fier avec ça à six
tours mon ami tu vas gagner de l'argent
et gary j'ai un bon plan pour toi pour
gagner de l'argent tu as me filer 500
euros et ont fait moitié-moitié comme ça
on mettre 250 balles chaque projet
bachelot au distributeur
gary j'ai encore une meilleure technique
pour devenir riche tu va retirer 500
euros
je peux pas 400 jeux tu retires 400 et
je mets 100 euros moi même au goût et là
on fait pas 55 ans mon gars ont fait 60
% pour toi et 40% pour moi c'est pas mal
quand même
à givet je vais chercher un truc apporte
une vraie coca cola peine c'est bon j'ai
de l'eau par contre tu peux me donner
l'équivalent de ce que tu voulais
m'offrir en euros s'il te plaît du coup
comme je veux pas
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 7 le 7 c'est
à dire que je suis à paris je suis
rentré hier
hier soir chez aller voir baranger
karine versant peu sonné on avait fait
l'alpha qu avec eux on a tapé le petit
boeuf
autant vous dire que c'était un peu
ridicule audi dante michel michel il a
pu de batterie michel but de battre il
va falloir recharger
monsieur philippe roesch quel jour
sommes nous
eh bien nous sommes jeu ça me dit on et
le 11 février
on est à paris on est sur la route de
versailles et il ya toujours philippe
roche en fait un c'est le thème de ce
blog de ce mois là c'est philippe roche
il conduit avec son appli c'est
incroyable
bref il y en a fait la première à
versailles ça s'est très bien passé
merci d'être venus abonnez-vous je rends
m'étais pause bleus et ce soit est un
soin particulier puisque à lille il ya
super connard tu n'est venu me voir
jouer et la ja top 10 si bien ce soir tu
coules top 10 le petit mito top 10 alias
arnaque sitôt cette grosse arnaque
décidément gros
qu'il y en a encore dans les
commentaires qui pense que l'explication
de l'arnaqué est elle même une arnaque
on va loin dans le complot chatt el
hillal complot il ya le complot des
habits bien tu vois si jamais demain le
livre je ferai le symbole des illuminati
la foule qui l'imaginent les illuminati
café théâtre
on est dans une cave on est en bas j'ai
joué là durant six mois tous les
vendredis c'était en 2012 dans quelle
année 2012 2012 2012
et c'était super je joue je jouais ici
là ici là et on mettait le public par là
et ça sortait souvent cette série à
philippe ross
d'ailleurs je m'étais vraiment le
running gag de blog du mois de février
qu'est ce qui se passe quelques secondes
avant le spectacle je suis là je suis en
train de stresser je m'habille hectares
et puis après je prends cette petite
route là là je passe par la up
ici c'est noir salle là vous vous êtes
juste là moi je fais un petit pas un
petit pas d'élan comme ça sic pour me
faufiler la marché sur les marches au
mont garizim m et des jolis trace
blanche sinon je me fais ta gueule dans
le noir et on rigole pas et après
j'arrive sur scène juste par la chaleur
wal fadjri vous avez vu comment il est
joli ce lieu si vous êtes un jour de
passage là c'est à versailles s'appelle
l'hapoel factory je suis vraiment
amoureux de ses théâtres
c'est une création à 100% ils ont fait
un lieu regarde les illustres là tous
les sièges et tout ça c'est magnifique
car très joli noeud qui arrive bat
philipp roth donc là on met à côté de
cette magnifique scène on se bat pour
mon micro philippe roesch quelqu'un
d'important
alors fabien désolé c'est vrai que je
suis souvent avec toi mais c'est pour
une bonne raison c'est parce qu'en fait
tu adores limitation tu es un super bon
imitateur
c'est vrai que sortie de krasucki ou
encore nos anciens présidents globaux
foire n'a pas grand chose mais mais
quand même si vous demandez de faire si
mon époux bas aussi demandez-lui cesser
ces petits défis comme ça de d'imitation
il est très très fort faites le aussi
quoi parce que ben parce que c'est seul
en fait un artiste mais même si vous
êtes nombreux à suivre
abondant dans les galas les hôtels et et
voilà les loges comme ça on est on se
retrouve souvent tout seul 1 face à soi
même donc donc bien voilà je suis son
son imitateur sa petite lumière la
tournée sont son rossignol
en attendant le rossignol va aller sur
scène parce que moi aussi j'ai le droit
de répéter
[Musique]
et vous avez vu le travail de ce mec
c'est énorme
arriver à faire ça tu vois ce que lire
les heures de boulot pour que l'élève
reçoit people en même temps que la bande
son c'est incroyable qu'est ce que je te
disais je passe ma vie à me faire vanner
par ce médecin bon ben on est plutôt pas
mal
réponse de la gym et s'enfoncer sous
utilisé et deux secondes sur ma voix
quand tu faisais des réglages on appelle
ça les mecs mentaliser ça veut dire
qu'il ya eu du déchet nous sommes le 16
février je n'arrivais à chronofoot a de
la basse cour où je suis venu jouer ici
à 2015
et si je suis avec diablo d'uploader si
je t'attrape justement résumé des
épisodes précédents je suis en train de
repasser sur les livres ça toujours
j'avance bien sur le chemin fermenteurs
j'espère que ça va vous plaire par
contre je parle très très mal parce que
je suis malade même genre débouchés se
baser ce médecin non pas chez ce médecin
chez les médecins sept sur sept est ce
que ce médecin ils m'ont dit grosso modo
sun nous intéresse pas trop trop trop
venez dans une autre ville mais vraiment
donc donc géant des 50 minutes chez le
médecin
et voilà la sarre est un petit peu chaud
chez les petites suez où tu peux te
taire je moi je parle avec quatre cent
mille personnes
il se rend pas compte il a il a une
télévision il a cinq chaînes dessus et
dans une crypte et celles qui regardent
le plus là par exemple il croit que je
téléphone on le voit qu'il est pas net
[Musique]
c'est pas facile la tournée donc en
attendant le médecin ça me laisse quand
même le temps de me de m'installer sur
le plateau alors c'est parti
oui
c'est pas fini et j'étais en train de
réviser petit et pis c'est tout nous
sommes aujourd'hui monsieur grec de le
dos de les lots de lait l'eau on est
quelques jours vendredi
évidemment je présente aux grecs c'est
lui qui a inspiré le personnage de
grincheux mais sans son bonnet 16 ou à
moi il est donc 15h44 je ne suis pas
encore changé mais pourquoi mais parce
que j'ai quelqu'un qui vient dans
l'élevage c'est sociaux youtube
wesh comme a dit soi des jeunes rappelle
que les gens attendent de toi que tu
faisais la musique
non non et non
malaise c'est vrai c'est très bluffant
c'est extrêmement bluffant ce mec comme
ça tout le temps il peut faire tu t'es
que ça abonnez vous y rendre vous vous
souvenez dans le blog du mot dernier
j'avais une voix un peu grave et/ou
l'euro parce que j'étais malade
eh ben voilà c'est reparti on entend que
ma voix ce bar un peu dans les aigus
elle fait ce qu'elle veut c'est ouf
c'était bhl le pire c'est que cet après
midi je voulais faire plein de choses je
sortis la vidéo de ce matin et tout et
je me suis rendormi tout l'après-midi
cole genre le corps et me dis stop se
termine et fabien et c'est donc la
dernière soirée de cette première
semaine à la basse cour à grenoble et je
vais rejoindre mon diablo heures
de retour au top de la basse cour à
grenoble quel genre d'homme nos diables
hasard 22,5 25 24 23
[Musique]
j'ai la pression pour les gens en train
de revoir plein de chapitres il faut que
je rentre dimanche dernier carat mais
j'ai grave de choses à faire cette
semaine
dire que là il faut que je retourne au
théâtre pour faire la mise en place et
puis pour faire le spectacle
et oui demain matin je serais un escape
game avec jardin new tunes c'est pitié
blows or ça va être drôle
l'après midi je fais une vidéo que vous
aurez déjà vu entre temps avec as de
pique et j'ai trouvé aussi une nouvelle
méthode pour gagner de l'argent
harnes à quito volume 4 si vous me
suivez sur snap ou twitter ou instable
même facebook je l'aimé je me par tous
il a tellement il faisait rire vous
l'avez vu passer sinon je vais vous le
remettre là et si vous ne suivez pas sur
les réseaux sociaux
ouais me rejoindre je suis au taquet
dessus j'adore ça et vous avez tous les
liens dans la description ya toujours
tout dans la description mon diablo j'ai
un bon plan pour toi je te parie 10
euros que tu me donnes 20 euros x glide
attendre 40 je te parie je te paraît dix
balles que j'y arrive je marche un
génial qu'un 20 40 10 euros et pas un
euro tu vois je t'ai parier guibal que
je te rendrai sa rente et b tu sais quoi
j'étais un peu présomptueux je crois que
j'ai raté mon pari du coup je te je te
rends tu dis parce que je tiens à payer
mes dettes et je t'avais parier 10 euros
que je te rendrai 40g paraissait
attendre 40 très bien je paie mes d'elle
je te paie les 10 euros je me suis fait
avoir la tsa et nous sommes maintenant
le 28 février je peux le prouver grâce à
ce petit calendrier digital depuis le
mois d'octobre vous avez vu des vidéos
dans ce bureau qui était complètement
vide
et au fur à mesure vous avez des choses
arriver et bien là il est terminé enfin
je pense qu'il est terminé et si vous
voulez je vous fais une petite visite en
une minute des familles si un jour vous
venez au bureau vous allez rentrer par
ici et vous allez tomber sur ça ça c'est
mon ancien rétroprojecteur que j'ai
ramené dans le bureau du coup pour
afficher sur ce mur
le petit canapé parfait canapé qui m'a
été offert par cdiscount com pas mal de
choses en fait ici je voudrais vraiment
les remercier et je vous mets un lien
dans la description si vous aussi vous
voulez des trucs d'aménagement en fait
j'avais déjà passé une commande chez eux
de pas mal de chose est sûre la commande
d'après ils m'ont contacté pour me
proposer de m'aider à meubler le bureau
merci c'est énorme ça c'est ça c'est
très sympathique
on apprécie beaucoup donc si on continue
appelée petite étagère qui vont bien au
ça c'est mon boullier le petit meuble
avec le mano solo que j'avais dessiné
chez mon pote zapata bien
sur la lumière ne restent pas là en
permanence le bureau le fameux trophée
des 100000 le fameux trou est fait sans
vous la qui regardez la vidéo vous êtes
là dedans vous faites partie en fait je
vous ai rangé dans une boîte ya
longtemps et je vous garde près de moi
ça c'est si voulu me voir également sur
scène d'un spectacle d'humour mais qui
parle de mentalisme durant plus d'une
heure et demie ce mois ci je serai à
lyon à narbonne à bordeaux à valence à
toulouse à montauban et après il ya
encore plein d'autres villes les autres
moi vous avez un lien vers les dates de
spectacles la description si à un moment
donné vous avez besoin de vous isoler il
y à des toilettes et enfin ce qu'on
appelle communément un débarras michel
micheline toujours prêt à partir au
combat ça s'était dit ça me fait penser
je vous ai pas présenté ibra joue le
présentateur alors ça c'est ibra et ibra
il fait quoi il est ce pas un pouce
bleus non je donne des noms à mes objets
parce que oui parfois dans un bureau ce
sens a lu un truc que je vous ai pas dit
c'est que depuis le mois de janvier on
est complet toutes les dates du
spectacle partout où on passe en tournée
c'est génial merci c'est un vrai kif de
vous voir à chaque fois à la fin on
prend du temps s'écoule le 18 mai je
vous le dis ici parce que assez peu de
personnes iront au bout de cette vidéo
il ya mon livre qui sort qui va
s'appeler votre cerveau est
extraordinaire
j'espère qu'il vous plaira c'était très
bizarre là d'envoyer toutes les
dernières corrections à l'éditeur de dix
ans maintenant je peux plus rien toucher
en fait et puis si cette vidéo vous a
plu vous pouvez lalique et c'est
important vous pouvez également vous
abonner à la chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà
fait et rendez vous très bientôt ciao
[Musique]